Allah is transcendent
and he's not bound by any
contradictions.
Since he is not bound by any
contradictions, so why he can't create a
stone that he cannot lift? So how to
answer this question?
And this is a common question asked in
the time when I was in school that can
go create anything and everything and we
say yes.
Can God destroy anything and everything?
And we say yes. So can God create a
thing which he cannot destroy?
And we stuck. If you say yes also you
are wrong. If you say no also you're
wrong. And similar question can God
create anything and everything? We say
yes. Can God lift anything and
everything? We say yes. So can he create
a stone which he cannot lift? So these
questions actually as you rightly said
they are illogical
because
for example
if I say that there is a tall short man
it doesn't have any meaning you can
either have a tall man or a short man or
you can have a medium man you can't have
a tall short man it's meaningless for
example if I say that there's a fat thin
man you can have a fat man or a thin man
you can't have a fat thin man because
it's meaningless
So similarly Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
only does godly things. He does not do
ungodly things like creating a stone
which you cannot lift.
Like Allah does not lie
because to lie is against the concept of
Allah subhanaa tala. Allah says in the
Quran he's never unjust. Allah subhanaa
tala cannot do injustice. Allah says in
surah chapter 4 verse number 40 he
never unjust in the
further Allah subhanaa tala never
forgets Allah says in surah chapter
number 20 verse number 52 Allah never
forgets so can you forget
it is against
the benefits of Allah subhanaa tala
forget so here we say that Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala is all powerful and
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala cannot do
ungodly things.
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala only does
godly things. He doesn't do ungodly
things.
That's the reason Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala is the highest.
And what
we can learn is we learn from the s of
the prophet and the incidents which
increase our iman. Hope to answer this
question.